when I look around the world everyone's  so [ __ ] focused on ore this is better  than that  you know uh would this idea work as a  YouTube video or that should we have  this guest on our podcast or that is  this a good name or that  the reality is all the happiness and all  the opportunity in life is when you  realize and not or people try to push  their perspective on the world and then  thus thinking someone else is [ __ ]  wrong they'd have to be wrong what about  the fact that you can both be right when  they're thinking about content that they  need to put out post both the [ __ ]  ideas you have this insane infatuation  of society being so focused on being  right and that their thing is right and  that's not this or Obsession is [ __ ]  devastating your happiness and your  business fall in love with the word and  and watch it change